to the spectators weekly look ahead to
politics I'm Fraser Nelson and with me
on my colleagues is about Hardman and
Douglas Murray David Cameron is back
from holiday has lost no time in getting
stuck into Iraq here's a big piece of
Sunday Telegraph describing a
generational struggle against the
so-called Islamic state in Iraq and
Syria and this morning we've heard
Michael Fallon the new defense secretary
making very hawkish noises from Cyprus
about to the length of time we're going
to be in Iraq for this time around so
Isabel talked us through what's happened
over the last two days David Cameron is
struck of a rather hawkish tone hasn't
he he has Lee he hasn't given a huge
amount of detail about what he wants to
do he's sort of trying to set the case
make the case for a long engagement in
Iraq whether that's through he said aid
tip diplomacy and military prowess that
was the lists in that all of it he gave
yeah it seems I mean reading his article
here he says we should avoid sending
armies to fight or occupy so he's ruled
that out yes but at the same time and we
need to stem the onslaught of this
dangerous terrorist movement so we're
going to fight them but not with armies
is he basically saying in your campaign
what that certainly what Michael Fallon
seem to have been suggesting he sketched
out a lot more detail of what we're
already doing which does sound a lot
like military combat in some ways which
actually some MPs might want to be
consulted on before that starts in
earnest it seems to involve the RAF
getting involved with what America's
doing in Iraq to stop Isis it seems to
be also airdrops which were already
doing but Michael Fallon did also say
that some military personnel have been
on the ground to assist the Chinook's
that have gone over there but that's
obviously not quite the same as boots on
the ground in the way that we'll
politicians fear these days it's just
some boots on the ground alone
disappearing again
Douglas M this time last week we were
worried about a potential massacre in
the M Sinjar mountains and there was
going to be a rescue operation
we were a couple on Thursday morning to
read that Britain was about to join it
it was then canceled the Americans
decided their intelligence said that
there weren't as many up there as they
feared so are the air drops working are
we actually succeeding in providing aid
to them and this and also pushing Isis
back it's not clear but over the weekend
there have been a few developments on
that I mean there were a number of
airstrikes by American forces on
Saturday convoy several convoys not far
from Erbil actually and so obviously in
any of the any of the hits on Isis
targets are going to set Isis back a bit
the details of exactly what the math
Center situation is have been very
sketchy I have to say I think there's a
real lack of information both in the
media and it seems governmental level of
exactly what is going on here of course
they also the weekends there have been a
bit more detail coming out of of exactly
what these IDI populations have been
going through in areas where Isis has
taken control which I think will do
something to firm up a portion of public
and indeed political opinion that
something must be done well Michael
Fallon these new defense secretary he is
already sounding rather different to
Philip Hammond the news in that role
isn't it yes I think one of the reasons
for this is actually just that
microphones are very good communicator
he's very good let's be here but he's
also quite a blunt to communicate to us
also it may not be that there's been a
shift in the government's position it
may just be the fallon is happier to
give us more details of what they're up
to and when we heard him in RNA that
criteria yesterday he was dissing to the
trips i want you to know people back
home we're very proud of what you're
doing this is sort of wartime rhetoric
on this it seems to be which is funny
because david cameron had led us to
believe the parliament would be recalled
if he was to deploy force is it is a bit
unclear as to what the prime ministers
conditions are for parliament to be
recalls of a debate of a vote but it
does seem as if we're creeping towards
me and be
to compare to find themselves in the
middle of a third Iraq war are they well
I think this is probably the worry of
many MPs actually that they'll be
mission creep and that they won't be
consulted on it or even give given the
chance to scrutinize it
MPs obviously don't actually have power
over whether what we go to or is just
that the convention is that they are
consulted and Philip Hammond last week
I've written it down to striking the
number to Philip Hammond laughs it was
asked about recalling Parliament he said
we have a very clear convention about
consulting Parliament before British
forces are committed into any kind of
combat role but we're not talking about
that here that's talking about mission
creep I mean the Kurds are willing and
able and keen to take the fight to Isis
they now share a 600-mile border with
with these guys and we have in the
Kurdish army one of the most effective
fighting forces in the region but these
guys are fighting for something else on
there they're fighting for their own
independence might the outcome of this
be Britain helping Kurdistan in the
battle which might be remembered as it's
battle for independence yes it could
very well be the situation as I said
with the Kurdish issue in Iraq is that
post 2003
nobody wanted really to touch nobody in
international community wanted to touch
the issue of Kurdish independence
there's a very strong very legitimate
call for independence in the region from
the Kurds it does of course if it starts
in Iraq there was a problem that almost
every other neighboring country if
anybody has a call for Kurdish
independence in that country I mean you
end up mucking up and so on so nobody
really wanted to open that kind of worms
for that reason but also because there
was a I think legitimate belief post
2003 for the Kurds having had
effectively a ten year head start in
statehood thanks to the no-fly zones
after the first Gulf War that that
desire for statehood had to be sort of
quelled for a period because the Kurds
with this head start will be such a good
stabilizing influence in Iraq now I
think they have been a stabilizing
influence however at this stage more
than 10 years on from the second Iraq
war
the Kurdish call for independence is I
think going to become increasingly
difficult to resist partly because of
the sectarianism under the Maliki
administration which may well continue
under the new prime minister but also
simply that the the Kurdish experience
of being a stabilizing force could very
well be said at this stage to have
evaporated that this was beyond their
control that this was beyond their
ability to stabilize and that the
sectarian and indeed deeply conflicted
country which is now Iraq would be best
with them out and that they could
protect themselves and have their own
state I think that we will be hearing a
lot more of that in the coming months
and what do you think Isabel that
Britain's foreign policy is with the
Reiji so how strongly do you think we
still believe in the one Iraq policy I
mean if I imagine there's a new prime
minister in Baghdad
he's there ironically with American and
Iranian support they all agree it was
time that Malik you should go we've got
in somebody who's got sufficiently low
profile not to be resisted Racine is
intolerable
in Iraq but if we want Iraq to stay
together as a country it's crucial isn't
it that this new prime minister and
should be able to repair the damage done
and by Maliki should be able to
emphasize this is not a Shiite
government this is a Shiite and Sunni
government so in theory David Cameron
should be giving lots of support to
Baghdad when in fact we seem to be given
we've just appointed an ambassador to
Kurdistan it seems a special
representative to the region so do you
expect to be hearing much about that or
is this simply beyond Britain's
comprehension I'm not sure we know what
our policy is anymore but in so much as
there is one I think it's that we will
support the new prime minister so long
as he creates a genuinely United and
representative government and abandons
the sectarian policies of his
predecessor
and that's what Cameron has been saying
over the past few days that they will
support him and continue
but that's not really a policy beyond
just saying well you know well done and
good luck basically if there is a huge
set of problems down the line on this
Malcolm Rifkind piece this morning a
highlights part of this which is
effectively that what seems to be
Britain's current desires for Iraq
included necessary increasing closeness
between this country and for instance
the government of Iran yeah that is a
problem akin to the one which has been
highlighted many people have talked
about over the weekend of British forces
now going to war precisely with the kind
of people that only a year ago we were
talking about getting close to harming
of course the unions that all of us have
seen this movie before insofar as what
the last time there was a Sunni
insurgency it was led by Al Qaeda in
Iraq which we now know as Isis it was
defeated because the Sunni tribes
weren't encouraged to rise up and take
these guys on themselves by government
to Baghdad that was seen as being Sunni
and Shia now Kurdistan real particular
borders you can't really see them
clearing up western Iraq that can only
be done by an Iraqi army so oddly isn't
it within the interests of both Britain
and Iran but there should be an a
balanced and popular government in
Baghdad which is capable of inspiring
the Sunni tribes to do what we did seven
or eight years ago which is take the
fight to Isis yes I'd have to remember
that one of the reasons why that worked
in the 2007 period particularly was
because of a very very involved American
contribution very the best American
generals and others were involved in
making sure that the Sunni awakening
happened you know it's sort of very easy
rather like referendums if nothing
happens if it goes the way that everyone
wants and the status quo remains is very
easy to assume that was always going to
be the case it's very easy in hindsight
to think the Sunni awakening was always
going to happen it wasn't always going
to happen it happened with enormous
American
Oh